[MUSIC PLAYING]
>> A
question here from Rob from Loos, which is
think is in the UK,
asks, "You and others have talked about the
need to stop FGM within a
generation.
Do you really think you can do it?"
Kathy?
>> Well, there's a goal that the UN has set
that to eliminate by 2015
which is the date for the millennium development
goals.
I don't think there's any real we shouldn't
be trying for that.
That's far enough away that we could really
do a concerted effort and
frankly, it's going to take a global campaign,
you know.
And we need a global campaign for girls.
This ought to be right front and center at
the beginning of it.
So I think it's doable.
>> So there's a -- may be a parallel with
China, in that foot binding
existed for hundreds and hundreds of years.
And at various points -- I think in the Chen
Long Emperor or -- or --
it may have been before Chen Long.
But that foot binding was actually punishable
by exile on the part of
the parents -- had zero impact.
At various points, it was banned.
No impact.
And then early in the 20th century, really
remarkable quickly, it
disappeared.
And it went from a perception on the part
of parents that if they
didn't bind their daughter's feet, that it
would be hard for her to
marry, to a perception that if they bound
her feet, it would be harder
for her to get married.
And, um, it, you know, I guess that --
>> One emperor changed the rule.
Changed the perception.
>> It was a really a bottom-up social movement,
um, led by elites from
within the country, um, part of this sense
of awakening.
And supported by outsiders to some degree
but -- but really led from
within, pushed from within.
So I guess the question is how we can replicate
that, and whether
groups like COSTAND are indeed -- whether
this is the next sort of foot
binding analogy, so that the change once it
comes you've reached the
tipping point, it will happen very, very quickly.
>> I just want to come back to that point
Kathy made of 2015.
I wished I shared your optimism, Kathy.
I just feel that we're here talking about
solutions.
We seem to know what works.
We know this model is there.
We know about the respect we have to give
to communities.
Um, and many, many local NGOs and civil society
organizations are
working on the ground, and you know to pay
tribute to all of those
small organizations really at danger as well.
One of the women who's contacted me through
this campaign Lucy Maswa,
who said, you know, go forth and speak at
Davos about this.
And her story, once she started speaking out
within her community, she
was raped, she was beaten, she was tied to
a tree, she was jailed.
She's luckily living now in the US.
But I think what we need to see is how we
can in the next five years,
if that is true, take this to scale -- I'm
using the language of Davos
there -- but really, you know, what is preventing
us if we know how to
make things change, why can't we put this
into place?
It is a funding issue?
It is a global awareness issue?
What needs to happen?
What are the levers that we can pull?
If we were sitting here saying actually this
is to intractable; this is
too difficult.
We're not going to address this issue.
Fair enough.
But we're all sitting here in vehement agreement
that is a severe abuse
a child's right abuse, a women's right abuse.
We've got a solution.
What can we do?
[MUSIC PLAYING]